[Music]
today's question comes from kyle in
tampa
with gas being so expensive right now
i'm looking into selling my jeep and
getting a tesla my wife and i are going
way over budget on gas and it seems like
a good time to get an electric vehicle
even with the car market the way it is
she thinks it's a bad idea to finance a
car but i think it'll save us money in
the long run who wins the argument
oh dave loves this question i can see
the fumes coming out of your head right
now there's just so many things wrong
about his decision hey it's a tesla
uh be their payment dave i gotta see you
thought it was gonna be cheaper because
you have to pay the light bill bubba to
plug in your little car this is true i
got a comment yesterday on instagram a
guy said i don't trust a man who drives
an electric vehicle whoa
that's that's new for me
now i understand respect but trust i'm
untrustworthy because my car doesn't
have an engine like yours dave oh but
that's besides the point just now just
venting i mean you and rachel both both
of you are driving these batteries now i
mean it's and you're paying for our gas
thanks to the chargers out front now
that just pisses me off because the
people that work here
that drive gasoline vehicles don't get
free fuel so why is it that the landlord
is obligated to put out a little
plugging station i didn't decide that
you did
well some block codes or something like
like i don't know or maybe maybe my
maybe uh
wait
i know what it was
rachel's husband built the building this
is a conspiracy he's in cahoots he's in
cahoots he put those plugs out there so
he could end up because he knew she was
gonna end up buying one of those dadgum
things winston if you're listening be on
the watch that's what it is your
father-in-law is mad that's what it is
now i figured it out i see their scheme
well back to kyle's question here's the
thing i took a question like this
similarly the other day okay the young
guy yeah he's single and he said well
i'm in canada the petrol is very
expensive i'm just going to go finance a
60 000 tesla to save money because that
makes sense when you say that coming out
of your mouth does that not does that
not blow your brains out i mean it hurts
my brain so i'm gonna go finance 60 000
to save money how do you calculate the
roi the break even on a situation like
this obviously the financing side how do
you know what you actually pay
to fill up the stupid thing do you know
i i've done the math oh is it okay yeah
at home it's cheaper now if you're
charging out in public it's a little
more expensive but it's you know it's
like 13 cents a kilowatt and so you
multiply that by how many kilowatts okay
so what does it take to fix the car for
a week
for a week uh depending on your driving
i know but i mean you're driving back
forth to work here yeah i would say
about maybe
10 15 20 bucks okay for me so it's
substantially less than my gas yes my
gas might be 30 bucks in that same
period of time i mean we live about the
same distance from that yes so we don't
neither one of us drive that far okay so
if that was the case so you're saving
20 bucks
how long does it say take to get sixty
thousand dollars saving 20 bucks many
many years
maybe retirement longer than you're
going to live okay oh my god that's
stupid
so the excuse of i'm doing it to save on
gas that just doesn't cut it well you
are saving on gas but you're not saving
on money
well to them it's the same thing at this
point it's not just
i mean because
you know it's the same thing when i
first started teaching this stuff a
thousand years ago i had a guy in the
financial peace university class and he
drove one mile to work he was an
18-wheeler driver he drove over the road
so he would drive one mile to work park
his truck get into the 18-wheeler drive
for a week over the road come home get
back in his pickup and drive one mile
home wow he had an awesome
perfect cherry little
1978 pickup it was a kind of a classic
it was beautiful perfect there wasn't a
thing on the thing
comes and goes sold my truck
going why'd you sell your truck because
i wanted a new one
gas mileage was killing me
dude you dropped two miles a week the
gas mileage can't kill you how are you
gonna you're gonna break even on that
new one by driving it to the moon and
back maybe oh my gosh wow the break-even
analysis is what it's called people and
how long does it take you for to get
your money back with the money saved
that's a break-even analysis and the
point is it's going to take longer than
you live no you don't finance a tesla to
save money that's dumber than a rock
this happens a lot in the southern clear
world this you get these all the time
with solar panels it's the same idea
hey dave we're gonna get solar panels to
save on electricity it's gonna cost 50
000 to finance them
yeah but they don't cost 50 000 anymore
but uh
but i mean
they actually do have about a seven year
break even if you're in an expensive
if you're in a good sun area
and an expensive electric market and you
pay cash for them and you pay cash for
them they got about a six or seven year
break even which makes them yeah okay
but you're not gonna break even on tesla
while you're alive okay
so
and you're a tesla driver keep that in
mind yeah george here we go let's not
make it personal come on jordan here's
my question anytime someone says well
you and rachel you and rachel i'm just
i'm i'm
here well what did i say he doesn't
trust a guy that drives a bathroom he
doesn't trust a guy who doesn't have a
car with an engine in it that's his
that's his vibe hmm
so it sounds like he had cars in the
backyard up on blocks that didn't have
an engine in it
i don't know that i trust you at least
not with my car
oh man
that's cold i mean i like making fun of
y'all but they're actually very cool
cars they're really fast they are and
they're just they're they scare me
because they're too quiet oh so
there's fear dave that's it it's a
latent fear
i think it's clear is coming out as
anger how is the car moving without
witchcraft it's witchcraft that's what
it is my mom felt the same way about
harry potter when it came out yeah well
she was right about that too but the uh
uh yeah
but the
uh no i drove on things and it's because
all of a sudden you're going 60 and you
don't even know it because there's
nothing telling it's just a g-force
there's no other than your brains are
flying out the back of your head oh my
gosh and it's just um
i mean because i'm used to like hearing
a muffler when i'm going fast or
something kick in right i want to i want
to hear there's there's audio feedback
that says to your brain you are now
going fast the louder it is the better
that's the reason when there's no audio
telling you or you are now going fast it
scared the crap out of me because i was
like dad gum i'm in a neighborhood here
i'm about to break the
uh sound barrier or something right here
in the neighborhood well don't be scared
dave i'm yeah i'm i'm you're safe with
me and rachel i'm so it's not that i
don't trust you people it's i'm scared
of you
thank you for admitting it really now
what it comes down to i'm scared of you
george it took me one of your life goals
has now been accomplished whether it's
electric or whether it's gas you cannot
afford to buy a more expensive car to
save on the fuel
it all the break-even analysis almost
never works because the car is so much
more expensive than the fuel so you're
moving from a 3000 or 5000 or 10 000 car
to a 30 or a 50 or 60 000 car that
spread you're not going to recoup it in
fuel savings of any kind electric or gas
period and you're certainly not going to
be able to justify the payment under any
freaking circumstance so just don't do
it there's very very few exceptions to
that rule now if you're driving a
eight thousand dollar pickup that gets
four miles to the gallon and you trade
it for an eight thousand dollar honda
accord
yeah because you didn't spend any more
money and you don't have payments then
you would save money on your gas
bill but but what happens is is that the
human brain
melts down and says to you you're
allowed to buy a newer car with payments
and that tells you that your brain is
not working okay it's amazing how our
brains can justify those terrible
decisions because we go well on paper i
mean i'm going to save a lot of money
yeah i'll help you with the paper